the graph data structure is not the same
as a graph you may have learned about a
math class graphs are collections of
things and the relationships or
connections between them the data in a
graph are called nodes or vertices the
connections between the nodes are called
edges one example of graphs is a social
network where the nodes are you and
other people and the edges are whether
two people are friend with each other
there are two major types of graphs
directed and undirected undirected
graphs are graphs without any direction
on the edges between nodes directed
graphs are graphs with a direction and
its edges an example of an undirected
graph could be a social network the
nodes are people and the edges are
friendships an example of a directed
graph could be the internet and web page
links the nodes are web pages and the
directed edges are links to other pages
which might not necessarily point the
other way I'm going to show you three
ways to represent a graph the first way
is called an adjacency list this
representation for a graph associates
each vertex in the graph with the
collection of its neighboring vertices
or edges in this image a is connected to
B B is connected to a and C and C is
connected to B this is how you could
show a relationship with texts and here
is how you could show this adjacency
list with JavaScript this is an
undirected graph because it does not
show the direction of the edges this can
also be more simply represented as an
array where the nodes just have numbers
rather than string labels another way to
represent a graph is to put it in an
adjacency matrix an adjacency matrix is
a two-dimensional array where each
nested array has the same number of
elements as the outer array so it's
basically a matrix of numbers where the
numbers represent the edges zeroes means
there is no edge or relationship and one
means there is a relationship this table
shows an adjacency matrix to represent
the image you can see that the labels
for the nodes are on the top and left
now here's a JavaScript representation
of the same thing unlike an adjacency
list each row of the matrix has to have
the same number of elements as nodes in
the graph here we have a 3 by 3 matrix
which means we have 3 nodes our graph
and adjacency matrix can be used to
represent a directed graph here's a
graph where the second node has an edge
pointing toward the first node and then
the third node has an edge pointing to
the first node notice how the numbers in
the array change there are only ones
where a node is pointing toward another
node and since there are only two points
there are only two nodes the final way I
will show to represent a graph is an
incidence matrix like the adjacency
matrix and incidence matrix is a
two-dimensional array however the rows
and columns means something else here
the adjacency matrix use both rows and
columns to represent nodes and incidence
matrix uses roads rose to represent
nodes and the columns to represent edges
this means that we can have an uneven
number of rows and columns each column
will represent a unique edge also each
edge connects two nodes to show that
there is edge between two nodes you will
put a 1 in the two rows of a particular
column as you can see in the diagram
edge 1 is connected to nodes a and B now
look at the column for edge 1 in the
incidence matrix table you will see a 1
in both the a row and the B row this
shows the edge 1 connects the nodes a
and B here is a directed graph for a
directed graph use negative 1 for an
edge leaving a particular node and 1 for
an edge entering a node and here is a
JavaScript implementation of the
incidence matrix graphs can also have
weights on their edges so far we have
unweighted edges where just the presence
and lack
of edges binary zero one you can have
different weights depending on your
application a different way is
represented as a number greater than one
well now you know about different types
of graphs and how to represent them in
JavaScript in my next video about graphs
I will cover graph traversal algorithms
thanks for watching my name is Bo Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good